the i team has learned the person in
charge of managing the city of
henderson's money
has personally filed for bankruptcy not
once but twice
richard derrick was appointed the city
manager and ceo of henderson in 2018.
he was originally hired as the finance
director there in two thousand
ten court records reveal he and his wife
first filed for bankruptcy the year
prior
listing their assets and liabilities
both more than one million dollars
the properties they listed included a
home in seven hills as well as two
condos two cabins and some land in utah
the case was dismissed and the following
year records reveal they filed a second
time for bankruptcy
now our eye team reached out to richard
derrick and he provided a statement
which reads in part quote
like many individuals and businesses
that were devastated by the great
recession of 2008
i-2 suffered a financial loss on a
personal business investment
and made the difficult decision to
restructure the debt through bankruptcy
the i-team also reached out to the city
of henderson for comment
a spokesperson emailed us back saying
that city employees are not required to
disclose personal
financial information but the mayor and
council
are aware of derek's bankruptcy the
spokesperson also provided a statement
which reads in part
during his 21 years with the city
richard has demonstrated time and again
his strong capabilities for financial
planning
and proven his capacity to meet the
city's financial commitments
if you're interested you can read both
statements in their entirety on our
website
eight newsnow dot com